So far, we’re talked about how to define the
prediction target. Next, we introduce the Cohort
Construction step. Cohort construction
is about defining the study population.
For a given prediction target, there are
only a subset of patient that are relevant
among the whole patient-population,
and they are the Study Population.
Be aware, often we may not be possible to obtain
data from everybody in the study population.
As a result, the data set we studied is
only a subset of those Study Population.
So, the question is, how do we define the Study
Population? There are two different axes to
be considered. One the vertical axis, we have
prospective study versus retrospective study.
On the horizontal axis, we have cohort
study verses case-control study. Depending
on the combinations, we have four different
options: Prospective Cohort study, Prospective
Case-Control study, Retrospective Cohort
study, and Retrospective Case-Control study.
Prospective vs Retrospective
In a prospective study, we first
identify the cohort of patients, then decide what
information to collect and how to collect them.
Then start the data collection. In contrast,
in a retrospective study, we first identify the
patient cohort from existing data. For example,
past electronic health records of patients,
then retrieve all the data about the cohort.
In prospective study, we identify the cohort
and collect the data from scratch. But, in the
retrospective study, the data set already exists.
We just need to identify the
right subset and retrieve them.
Cohort Study
Next, let’s talk about cohort study.
In a cohort study, the goal is to select a group
of patients who are exposed to a particular risk,
for example, if we want to be in a predictive
model for predicting heart failure readmission.
Here heart failure readmission means,
heart failure patient after discharged
from the hospital, comes back again
to the hospital due to heart failure.
In this case, the cohort should contain all
the heart failure patients who discharged
from the hospital, because they can
potentially be readmitted after discharge.
The key in cohort study is to define the right
inclusion and exclusion criteria to figure out
what patient to include. Here’s a visual
illustration. We start with all patients,
then we try to identify the relevant
patient for a particular risk,
for example, these three patients are relevant
for this risk, such as heart failure readmission.
Then we want to build a model to predict the
target risk. In this case, the cohort contains
both positive and negative examples, for example,
patient with heart failure readmission and patient
without heart failure readmission. All this
relevant patient is a cohort in this study.
Case Control Study
The other common study design
is case-control study. In this design,
we try to identify two sets of patient,
namely cases and controls. And we put
them together to construct the cohort.
Cases are patients with positive outcome. For
example, the patient who develop the disease.
Controls are the patients with negative outcomes.
That is, they’re healthy patients, but otherwise
similar to the cases. For example, they can have
the same age, gender, and visit the same clinics.
The key here is to develop the matching
criteria between cases and controls.
For example, we want you to
predict a model of heart failure.
Then we identify a study population of over
50,000 patients, and we have 4,644 case patients.
Those are the patients who developed heart
failure. And we matched them against a set of
control patients on age, gender, and clinics.
And we end up with 45,000 control patients.
Notice that in this study, we have a lot fewer
cases with heart failures than the controls
without heart failures. This is pretty
typical because in a real world scenario,
patients with the specific disease
conditions are often harder to obtain,
while there are a lot more patients without that
disease are available to serve as a control.
To summarize, in a case-control
study, we first identify the cases,
then try to match them to a set of control
patients. In a cohort study, we’ll identify
all the patients who are exposed to the risk
and the matching criteria are not involved.